what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio presented by Saratoga
spring water it's time for an interview
I've really been looking forward to this
is the team behind infinity pool
holy I expect this from you this is
why I keep coming back for your movies
you take you take big swings and you
flesh out these worlds in a way that I
am wowed watching it and I can't stop
thinking about it after the fact
congratulations very kind of you thank
you so I obviously want to start with
you in terms of like the Genesis of the
idea can you tell me there's a lot going
on here what was the starting point idea
number one that kicked it all off and
then also do you remember the last part
of the story you came up with that kind
of brought it all together for you
um so it started with the first
execution scene I was sort of writing a
story actually that was just set
entirely in in that scene where
someone's watching themselves being
executed uh in this sort of fictional
State and and uh kind of relating to
this double of themselves and maybe
wondering which uh which version is real
um
what is the LA I have no memory of
anything that happened since then and
that was 2014 so
as you were either writing or going
through the production process is there
anything that came up organically along
the way that you never realized this
story needed when you first started
writing it
that's a good question and probably
there was a lot of it but I but I um
yeah I just can't remember I mean I
think that happens constantly you're
writing you start with sort of an
outline or I do you
kind of stick to it but it just the
characters start to
do surprising things and uh and you run
with that very very understandable I
want to go back to something you had
brought up when we were talking a little
bit about possessor and just the idea of
having such a bold story and being able
to convey what you want to achieve to
people like producers and financiers so
was there any particular part of this
story idea that was the most challenging
or maybe even the most intimidating to
convey to the necessary parties
you know it was kind of weirdly easy I
mean uh I was working with a lot of
friends and um uh you know film Forge
from Toronto they're all people I'm
really close to and so
um and then neon had put out possessors
so I don't know if they just
were too embarrassed to tell me that it
was a terrible idea or or what was going
on there but that they'd uh essentially
ran with it pretty quickly sometimes I
think if someone reads a script and says
it's a terrible idea you can't do this
that kind of makes me want to see that
even more and probably make makes me
think it has even more potential I will
bring that up next time I try to get a
film financed I'll I'll uh write that
down and sign it for you if you need for
all three of you now again big bold
story a lot of uh really big swings here
when you're gearing up for production
after reading the script what would you
say is the biggest burning question you
had for Brandon in terms of you know who
your character is or where they fit in
in this whole scenario
um well for me m is kind of the only one
reacting normally to the crazy horrific
things that are going down so for me I
was curious about the levels and really
just trying to find the truth of every
scenario and and make it feel as natural
as possible
hello
um
I feel I I don't
I was spending a lot of time trying to
figure out this relationship between
James and M because it's a married
couple and you meet them in the
beginning of the movie on this Resort
um and they are not in a good place it's
kind of
um James is struggling as a writer he's
a writer's block and they've gone down
there
um for for him to find some inspiration
and ironically it's this
um not very inspiring environment
because it's like a fake resort with
fake
um it's a little bubble so you don't
really see the culture around it uh
they're very sheltered
um
but it was we spent a lot of time
talking about and obviously with Brandon
as well about figuring out that
relationship
um and because it was important that
um it has to obviously feel real uh even
though it's broken now like there's got
to be something and that back figuring
out that backstory how they got together
and because that informs
um where we find them obviously and and
who James is
um once
the action kicks off and posed the first
execution
um
ironically that felt easier to me that
came quite naturally
um to kind of descend into that Abyss
um yeah that says a lot about you I
think it kind of does
me I want your answer as well but just
to stick with that relationship for a
quick second because this is something I
had considered Cleopatra had you ever
considered how this story might have
progressed if she was at the wheel of
the car at the beginning
that's a very good question
um
damn I don't know I feel like I mean M
is a kind of a buttoned up person and
there's this really pivotal moment in
which Mia's character has to convince us
not to
take the traditional route of like going
to the police and like reporting it
it's very scary for m so it's it's
possible that she would have done the
same thing but I don't know if she would
have been as corrupted as James ends up
being it's a very fair answer right
there all right I'll go back to my
original question for you Mia biggest
burning question about your character
her backstory or just what is happening
there wasn't just one big burning
question I I mean when I first read the
script uh Gabby my character she even
fooled me right so I thought I was being
presented with one woman and she just
kind of
took me on this journey and just left me
completely baffled and intrigued and
just really very impressed with her and
so I had a lot of questions about her
and how she presents herself and how at
first we're you know confronted with her
Persona the person that she thinks uh
you know James would want her to be uh
and then we're kind of as the film
progresses and she takes off that mask
we're kind of
confronted with uh
you know to me gabby represented
and really embodied these um deep animal
words is that we all had that we all
have sorry and I think
we just we spoke a lot it was a constant
Converse it was an ongoing conversation
and you know really Brandon just filled
me up with so much confidence in in
claiming my character and and and
allowing me to really make it what I
wanted so whatever felt right for me and
making sense of the world that I was in
then he was like go with that and that's
one of the things that I really loved
about working with Brandon is just that
you know there are parameters but
they're so wide and within this space
you're just able to be so free and and
and and explore this character as I
wished with that in mind Brandon I'm
curious about your approach to working
with your actors because last we spoke
you you brought up the fact that you
were constantly getting asked like how
did you get these performances out of
your actors I have a lot of issues with
that question that could probably go
into a whole video but
I was wondering what these particular
actors brought out of your own script
through their portrayal of the character
that you didn't even realize was there
to begin with
I mean it's hard it's hard to articulate
but really a lot because I mean for me
uh
you know by the time I'm actually
shooting I'm kind of bored of the
characters as written because I've been
with them for too long and as I don't
I'm not really looking for someone to uh
embody the thing that I thought the
character was gonna be from the start
what I do is I just there's certain
actors who are incredibly uh viscerally
exciting in in a kind of hard to
articulate way where you just sort of
see them they have whatever that thing
is none of them are making you know
boring choices they're the
you know
I don't know there's an energy to every
sort of scene you can they kind of in
any context uh light up the film in a
certain way I think we all kind of know
who those actors are some of them yeah
you tend to work with a lot of them yeah
all of these people at the table here
are like quite uh quite good at acting
so I like to take people like that who
have that energy who have uh whatever
that thing is plug them into a character
I've written and give them enough space
to uh wake the character up and you know
uh
come at them from an odd angle that sort
of surprises me and gets me excited
again about uh about the characters as
you're describing that my mind
immediately went back to Andrea rise
Brooks where we're talking about her a
lot rightfully so because of to Leslie
right now when you're casting what are
you specifically looking for in the
people that you could potentially work
with that signals to you that they have
those qualities again I think it's just
something you see I mean you know
sometimes there are particular
parameters age gender like you know a
character might for narrative reasons
have to
be a certain type of person but I think
you just you end up watching everything
that they've done
uh getting excited you know you've seen
one performance by one actor
uh that sparked with you in some way
then you go back and you watch their
stuff you go wow like they're really
consistently exciting this is really
amazing and then
it's just it's just kind of that like I
don't know I don't know how to explain
it it's sort of it's sort of a gut
instinct about certain performers
because they have that incredible uh
thing whatever that gut instinct Secret
Sauce is like you have it well Brandon
was a child because you couldn't get any
of those actors and you got with us was
that challenging for you as a director
yeah I mean I gave up pretty early
um
but I also think that's a testament to
what an amazing director you are because
you have to make do with
actors oh please I do I do want
non-actors is normally what they're
referred to as non-actors I want the
three of you to sing his Praises for a
little bit because when you're dealing
with this material with material like
this I imagine you need a leader and
someone who could set a certain tone and
environment on set to make you feel safe
and supportive when taking big swings so
what did you notice Brandon doing that
gave you that feeling that you really
appreciated
I think something I noticed right away
is how much he enjoys doing what he does
and I think that really comes through
like I personally I love being on sets
like my favorite place in the world and
it was really nice to share that
enthusiasm with someone who's also like
damn good at what they do and has such
an amazing imagination like reading his
script like you just never know what's
going to happen and it's
it was incredibly immersive and unusual
and strange and tonally like hard to pin
down which I think is exciting
yeah one of my favorite things was
um
it's a Brandon collaborates with a lot
of
people back that go back to like short
films 15 years ago and
um to see Brandon with his team of close
friends and collaborators and uh Kareem
RDP to see the two of them
um
is
be so playful and have so much fun on
set
it creates an environment that is uh
it's just
great for creativity for all of us I
think in front of camera because you see
that there's so much joy and happiness
and curiosity from Brandon and Kareem
and
um
and also the visual quality of it
everything there was nothing
done imposed I mean a lot was unimposed
but not no CGI it was all in camera
effects and how uh uh like little kids
playing with Lego like to see Brandon
and Kareem play with stuff and different
lenses and and and obstruct the view of
of the camera and different creative
ways and playing around with these weird
Prosthetics that they had and again just
to see that um and to be part of of that
um playful fun environment was just
really exciting to me I feel like sex
should always feel that way because
that's it's unfortunately not always the
case on set sometimes it feels like
paint my numbers and this was so playful
and fun and everyone
um wanted to be surprised and discover
new things and that was extremely
exciting to me
well
um
I had been a fan of Brandon's work for a
very long time and when I received the
script uh
I was actually filming Paul at the time
in New Zealand and uh we were on this
intense shoot we were doing six day
weeks 15 16 hour days and I get this
email and I saw the title of of the film
and then I saw Brandon's name and I just
thought to myself oh my gosh like I
couldn't actually believe it and I got
there and and I really wasn't open to
reading anything but on my one Sunday
off I got my coffee and I started
reading the script and I knew
three four pages and I was like yeah I
knew this is special I have to be a part
of this makes all the sense in the world
I've been dying to ask you about the
rating on this movie because that system
tends to be very confusing and not very
consistent so can you kind of give us
like you know a peek behind the curtain
on how it goes when you get a certain
rating and you want to adhere to your
original vision for a story but also
have to make certain concessions to I
don't know I guess make sure it has the
widest possible audience based on
standards that don't necessarily apply
to A Creative Vision right I mean the US
has a sort of particular issue because
of the NC-17 ratings nc17 was an attempt
to Rebrand the X rating but they didn't
do it successfully and it came with all
the sort of stigma you can't actually
Market a film if it had if it's an NC-17
reading so
uh specifically in the U.S uh that means
that you
can't really have a theatrical release
of any of any size
um but I mean I know that going into it
you know and it's not a problem
everywhere and and you know usually
there's a plan to release the the full
film it's not
the R-rated version isn't hugely
different I should say it's not like you
know I would love people to just see it
in theaters and not worry about the
versioning it's fine
um but I think you just you know film is
a on some level a very pragmatic art
form there's a lot that you have to deal
with there's a whole industry and so you
just
uh do everything you can creatively but
you uh to to sort of satisfy yourself
but then you understand that they're
just
you know aspects of the industry that
you have to deal with and that that kind
of comes with uh with the terrain
it's very diplomatic approach I
appreciate it
um before they make me say goodbye to
you all I have to talk about a couple of
upcoming projects I don't know if I'll
get to everyone I have something for
everybody but I'm coming your way first
Mia I think what what I had heard was
you said something like Maxine was the
best of this the three scripts and I was
wondering if you could tease like not
story specifics of course but but what
feeling does that have that makes it the
best of the three because you know how
much I love X and pearl so it's hard to
imagine getting something better
yeah I mean
what can I say it's uh
it's just such a fun film I I Tai really
I I mean I don't know how he does it
he's just able to
come up with these worlds and it's just
the biggest of the of the three movies
the stakes are the highest and you know
Maxine has been through so much at this
point and she's just such a badass
character in you it's not the kind of
person that you want to to cross the
wrong way and so you know she's gonna
protect
you know what she has and it's just uh
it's a wild it's gonna be I don't know I
really don't know what I can say without
but it's my favorite script of the three
you probably can't answer this but I'll
at least try because you use the word
big do you mean in terms of scope
because the other two films felt so
contained to that property for the most
part at least
yeah the it's uh
the biggest Stakes the biggest world
it's uh I really don't know I should
have I feel for you right now so much I
should have probably thought about this
a little more but I I it's I'm very
excited I'm in the middle of prep and
it's I'm having a lot of fun with all
the faith in the world I'm so excited
for that I'm also excited for certain
someone's directorial debut makes me
really happy when actors I admire get
behind the lens and start to explore
that realm and also help get projects
they're passionate about off the ground
and I'm curious for you given all your
acting experience how has that
influenced the casting process on your
movie is there anything that you've
experienced in an actor director
relationship that now you're looking for
and actors you're going to work with as
the Director
um
I should have said the movie The Pack
it's called the pack yeah it's an
ensemble piece so it's uh it's obviously
about finding the right group and the
right um chemistry and uh
um
my goal is to cast people I love and
some of my close friends and uh
um
it's been interesting being on this side
of a casting process it's been I've
learned a lot it's been sometimes it's
quite disheartening with in terms of
people's value and on some of those
conversations are
a bit um with financiers and everything
it's like
when you start to understand that model
of foreign territories of someone's
value and and someone you think is
amazing and you think would mean a lot
for financing doesn't and then someone
the opposite means a lot who you don't
get why
um so it is that um
what Miranda said it's
I think
um you're gonna have to make a lot of
compromises but you got to choose your
battles and figure out when it comes to
Casting obviously um
it's it's crucial to for me to
do with the with the the the actors I
want to work with and and find that
chemistry and that group uh otherwise
um
it's not worth it for me I'm not uh I'm
pretty content being
quote unquote just an actor so it's not
that I feel like I have to segue into
directing
um
I was on high on painkillers and had
hubris and thought I could direct this
for a second and maybe that was a
mistake uh
but uh
um we'll see we'll see I don't believe
that for a second and it it is an
achievement in and of itself to get the
go ahead to make your future directorial
debut so I will say an early
congratulations on that thank you
Cleopatra Rebel Moon I'm so curious
about that one
um I'm a big fan of Zacks and I I know
that that story idea was originally a
Star Wars pitch so can you maybe tease
you know what Star Wars fans or fans of
those types of movies will get from
Rebel moon but then also what is
something that makes it different and
stand out in terms of sci-fi fantasy
films
this is tough I saved the hardest
questions for last I real there's really
not much that I can say
um
but I will say that Zach is another
director that really enjoys what he does
he comes at it with such
enthusiasm he's camera operating he's in
the trenches with everyone
uh and it's a Fantastical world that
he's created I think people are going to
really love the action the actors worked
extremely hard on the stunts and it it's
going to look really beautiful it's it's
gonna be epic that's all I can really
say I can't give it away
all directors that you've brought up and
you included where I feel like the
passion for the craft and the story
they're telling leaps off the screen
that's what keeps me coming back for
more huge congratulations on infinity
pool enjoy celebrating it at Sundance
thank you so much thank you so much
thank you everybody out there keep an
eye out for the movie yourselves it hits
theaters very soon and stay tuned we
have more Sundance 2023 interviews on
the way